[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Richard Tice and the Isabella Oak
shot
sturgeon dramatically resigns as the SMP
leader today was her meltdown over the
trans right throughout the gamble that
finally backfired and what's left of her
independence dream we'll ask two of the
big Independence Movement Alex salmond
and Ian Blackford
Labor's secure Stormer pledges
patriotism and warns the hard left back
me or quit does chaos in Scotland pave
his path to power we'll be debating that
plus bake off stain pre-relief lobbies
MPS to legalize assisted dying her MP
son is standing in her way he joins us
live
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and
Isabelle Oak shots yeah
they've been three big beasties in
Scottish politics in recent years and
today the third one Nicholas sturgeon
suddenly resigned
did she jump before she was pushed as
leader of the SMP well we've got the
other two big beasties Alex salmond and
Ian Blackford live on our show tonight
as we explore what was behind sturgeon's
bombshell announcement what does it mean
for Scottish nationalism and indeed the
whole of the UK political scene in a
long heartfelt passionate resignation
speech she acknowledged that she's
become too divisive but with a worrying
absence of any other big beasts apart
from those joining us this evening will
her departure boost her party and the
independence cause
or will it be essentially the moment
where we've seen Peak SMP Peak sturgeon
it's all over
after all the SMP is up against a few
gigantic perhaps insurmountable
roadblocks to their dream of breaking up
the union and going Their Own Way Beyond
the fact that according to the most
recent polling the significant majority
of Scots are actually against it brexit
send them into a complete frenzy they're
desperate to rejoin the EU but they can
see just how challenging it's been for
the UK to leave the EU imagine after 300
years how much worse it would be for
Scotland trying to leave the rest of the
UK extraordinary we've been joined at
the hip for 300 years
well in a moment we'll be speaking to
the snp's former leader in Westminster
Ian Blackford but first let's hear from
former Scottish first Minister now
leader of Alba party Alex salmon Alex
thanks for joining us well absolute
bombshell announcement today from
Nicholas sturgeon did you see this
coming
no I didn't Isabella it took me by
surprise and I think it took everybody
by surprise you may get one of two
journalists claiming the new all along
but I don't believe them I think
everybody was fair astounded this
morning what what do you think is behind
her decision I mean she was at Payne's
in that very long resignation statement
to emphasize that it's not short-term
pressures I think that was an allusion
to the very toxic trans rights rail that
has been bubbling around for the last
few days so if it wasn't that that
pushed her over the edge what do you
think it was
I I don't know Isabel I mean they I I
certainly don't think it was the trans
reforms the the the transgender rights
reforms I mean that was a difficult
situation and Nicola made missteps she
was losing support it was damaging
Independence but you know that's the
sort of thing where if you come to a
compromise if you settle it if you do a
compromise with your Rebel benches you
know government's difficult you you come
into difficulties and challenges but
usually what happens is you deal with
them and then move on so it wouldn't
have done long-term damage to to the
independence case all indeed to the SMP
if it had been settled assembly with
other things that are going on at the
present moment there's huge problems in
the Health Service and education system
there's this problem with this to bring
back bottle return scheme but I mean
these are things which is the job of
government to face them and to overcome
them so I don't rate these that's why I
was so puzzled there I don't I don't see
in any of these any insurmountable
difficulties and I suppose the real
question about my surprise is is Nicola
was mid-stream in a two-pronged strategy
she had gone to the Supreme Court got a
note back she said she was going to have
a de facto referendum in next year's
general election and she's halfway
through that strategy which seems an
extraordinary time to to step down I
mean perhaps the problem is that the
strategy is going nowhere you'll have
seen the Lord Ashcroft polling from
earlier in this week which shows a quite
significant margin in favor of staying
in the union every which way she's
turned it looks like her campaign was
going nowhere perhaps that's the problem
that's the reason she's quit well you
know Paul's come and go I mean if we've
been having this discussion six weeks
ago you'd had a runner pull showing a
significant majority in favor of
Independence and you know I think the
reason for recent poll disappointments
for the SMP and indeed for for
Independence it was in the difficulty
she'd got herself into but the way you
do that is you overcome these
difficulties and and move on I mean the
underlying position is the support for
Independence and staying in the union is
about 50 50. now I could just remind
Joseph when I called the referendum in
2012 for 2014 support for Independence
was about 30 so even that's not a reason
I I find that very perplexing that this
is a moment she chose to go
um Alex essentially the three big beasts
uh of Scottish politics Nicholas
sturgeon yourself Ian Blackford
um you've all recently relatively
recently uh stepped down I mean what
next what for you Alex is it is this
possibly the moment where we're actually
almost a bit like Boris Johnson you're
tempted to go back
well can I say that I think the smpo
elect a new leader and they're there for
a new first Minister and what happens to
the SMP and to Scottish politics will
depend on what that person does I mean I
I I get these uh sort of celebrations
from notorian labor people saying oh
this is wonderful we'll we'll have all
our own way now I saw the same
celebrations after the referendum in
2014 and six months later they lost all
their seats so it really depends what
type of leadership the national movement
gets and in particular where you have a
leader who'll reunify the movement and
bring all parties all parts of it
together perhaps in an independence
condition Alex could that be you
no the the past is going to be the past
elected by the SMP I'm not a member of
the SMP I'm leading a rival political
party
but you can bring people together
through an independence convention which
is once a an idea which Nicholas
supported and that way you unite the
movement and get on with taking on the
unionists and get back to arguing the
fundamental case for Scottish
independence which is a case in economic
terms like you know why should energy
rich Scotland have a million people in
fuel poverty in constitutional terms
it's about the right of
self-determination something you should
recognize right not some of the other
issues that the the SMP government have
got themselves immersed in indeed I mean
Alec the reality is that this campaign
for Independence is going to take a very
high profile influential powerful figure
to get it to the next stage at the
moment with the greatest of respect to
those who are likely to throw their hat
into the ring they're not National
figures we with huge profile you buy
contract trust are I hear what you're
saying you're currently the leader of
another party it doesn't have any
representation is there any way back for
you do you think into the SNP well
elephant of two MPS Westminster Isabella
and I mean that may not seem very much
but when I led the SMP for the very
first time some years ago the s p only
had four MPS at Westminster and now
they'll they've got a whole Battalion uh
and indeed dominate Scottish politics so
look they they don't have to be leader
of the s p and first minister to make a
contribution to the independence
campaign and my hope would be that
whoever the new leader of the SMP is and
whoever's the new first Minister he or
she will will reunite the movement and
get everybody from the various political
parties but even more importantly from
the the cross party in non-party groups
in groups like common wheel who've come
up with some terrific policy ideas from
the Independent Scotland we've got all
these people working together in an
independence convention thank you Alex
brilliant well let's bring in Ian now
Ian good evening thanks for joining us
on Piers Morgan uncensored so this was a
massive shock to most people at mayor
may not have been to yourself but what's
happened here has has Nicholas sturgeon
realized that she'd become too divisive
a figure or or is there something else
involved
I think the fact is Nicola has been
involved with the the SNP over I don't
like she's been first Minister since
2014 and indeed was Deputy first
Minister before that right back to 2007
so she's had a long time in Frontline
politics a long time in government and I
think she's taking the decision that
it's right that she has a bit of me time
that
politics being a government is something
that is all-consuming it's it's 24 7
it's 365 days a year Alex knows that and
I think she's taking the decision that
given that she's been in office for so
long it is time to move on and it's time
that I think having laid the foundations
for the SNP to move on and to be able to
put that case for Scotland to become an
independent country that she wants to
pass that that battery I'm saddened I
didn't want her to go
um but I think it's right for her that
she's taken the decision that she has
and it may be right for her but what
about for the SMP is this a moment of
new opportunity new Revival for the SMP
or actually is this sort of we've seen
uh Peak sturgeon Peak SMP and it's a
sort of gradual slide down the slippery
slope for you we would never kick
anything for granted Richard but we've
of course been in government in Scotland
since 2007 Nicholas won every election
that she's fought as leader beginning
with the the Westminster election in
2015 we have a of course a Westminster
election coming down the tracks at some
point in the next uh two-year period
just under two-year period we've got a
Hollywood election in 2026 we've got to
make sure that we can enforce the
Mandate that we were given by the people
of Scotland at that last election then
when Alex talked about democracy but the
simple fact remains richer that there is
an independence majority in that
Parliament we often hear about this
being a union of consent so what are the
circumstances that the people of
Scotland that rightfully have their say
in their country's future and I know a
lot of the discussions that we have are
about process but at the end of the day
we need to have that to be about
Scotland's future well I mean
unfortunately unfortunately for you
process is the great roadblock to this I
mean Westminster will not allow you to
have this referendum that Nicholas
surgeon said she wanted to have uh you
can't overcome that you can't short
circuit it to what extent was the
division within the party over whether
the next election should be a de facto
referendum on Independence one of the
key factors for Nicholas sturgeon's
resignation
well you know in the sap that's a matter
for the members and what what Nicola had
recognized that the party was going to
have to have a a conference to debate
those matters that will still happen at
some point in the in the very near
future but you know you you've raised
tonight a couple of occasions the issue
of the transgender recognition bill
there's something quite extraordinary
that's taking place actually because
that was a bill that was passed by a
majority of parliamentarians cross-party
in support of msps of every party it was
a matter which was in the manifesto of a
number of parties at that last election
but we're now in the situation that
before that bill got royal assent the
Secretary of State for Scotland has used
his powers and shrined in the Scotland
act to strike down that bill and that's
an extraordinary set of circumstances
which which westminster's entitles do um
just finally Ian we must ask that's a
very important position of democracy and
the rights of and the respect that has
to be shown to the to the Scottish
Parliament Richard no indeed so are you
tempted to throw your hat in the ring
Ian I mean this is your big chance your
big moment
I will I will support whoever the the
new leader is but fundamentally we're
talking about someone that becomes the
leader of the SNP and becomes the first
minister of Scotland you really have to
be a member of the Scottish Parliament
for uh to stand in this election
well thank you very much in Blackford
for joining us thank you to discuss that
extraordinary news extraordinary thank
you and thank you Alex and I I totally
was not expecting this today you know it
is true to say there's been quite a lot
of Rumblings about Nicholas sturgeon's
political future and particularly in the
wake of that Ashcroft polling uh which
was you know however Alec and Ian tried
to frame it it was pretty negative for
them yeah my sense is that actually she
recognized she was too divisive myself
she said that and she said that my sense
is that actually this could be good for
the SMP it might be a sort of moment of
renewed interest different personality
New Blood fresh blood so yeah I think
it's I think it's going to be absolutely
fascinating but of course if it's
someone they're all both slightly
hedging their bets there as to whether
they would stand it seemed to me well I
mean I think there are a couple of
process issues there on there I mean
they're not both in a position to do so
but I think Alex salmon would probably
love to do it if he could
there we are oh well next tonight so
sakir starmer tells the left of his
party to back him or find a new home is
the labor party ready for power what an
alarming thought what about that next
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
welcome back well secure Stormer talked
tough in a major speech today recasting
the labor party as patriotic and ready
to lead he says labor has vanquished
anti-Semitism and the hard left
confirming Jeremy corbyn will not stand
again for the party he once LED
sturgeon's shock resignation
overshadowed stormer's speech but did it
also help pave his path to number 10.
well joining us now is associate editor
of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and
talk TV contributor Esther kraku and
down the line we've got former labor MP
Chris Williamson who was suspended for
uh for denying the party had an
anti-Semitism problem we'll talk to
Chris in just a moment but firstly Kevin
and Esther I mean this was such a shock
yeah but what's really gone on here she
hasn't given this up voluntarily I mean
Kevin is the what what's behind the
scene what's going to come out in the
next few days yeah that's what that's
what we're searching for because a
couple of weeks back she said she had
plenty left in the tank today she said
she was running on empty she was
planning the next general election it
was going to be effectively a referendum
on Independence she said all of a sudden
she's gone well we've seen her poll
ratings and respect for a collapse over
the the trans issue but also hanging
over the SMP uh is this inquiry by the
police and allegations of fraud on
funding and the use of money that was
supposed to be set aside for the
referendum one of the spending now her
husband
is the chief executive yes she exists in
her own right but you can't uh ignore
the relationship you'll all know about
power couples and politics you know
yourselves and that but there we have
one right at the heart of Scottish
politics Esther do you think that the
trans Rao however much she denies it do
you think that that tip to her over the
edge I actually think it was the inquiry
that that was the straw that broke the
camel's back I think the trans issue
what she was hoping for was was that it
would blow over because it always does
there's always some sort of huge row
about you know a male being swimming in
swimming in a woman's competitions
exactly and all of that and then they'd
blow over but I think this really did
her in because it's just a compounded
clip of uh of that
the question is are all trans women
women they haven't answered that
question well that's not the point that
we're dealing with the question trans
women are women but in the present
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman there are context where a
trans woman is not a woman no there is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate is there any context in which a
woman born as a woman will be housed in
the real estate look we're talking here
about trans women I'm now asking about
women born as women I don't think there
are circumstances there but it's
different for trans women well yes
just finally does it help or hinder
Kevin does it help with hinder the s p
her going uh the SMP no the s p is in a
bad place now there's no real strategy
and I think the thing is they haven't
cultivated any Superstars this is what
happens when you have a superstar you
don't breathe the next generation of
superstars in which case then the
question is what does that mean for
labor and we're joined now down the line
with uh Chris Williamson uh former MP
Chris very good evening thanks for
joining us on Piers Morgan uncensored so
the labor party has uh sakir starmer
he's uh he's done the right thing he's
cleansed itself the of the left he's
suggested that they find a new home is
that um how do you feel about that based
on your your tweets today
well I left the labor party in 2019. I
mean I think we had a unique moment in
history when Jeremy was elected as
leader in 2015 and we saw at the 2017
election the biggest increase in vote
share since 1945 what we didn't know of
course at that time was that so senior
figures in the Parliamentary labor party
and in the bureaucracy of the party were
actively working against a labor Victory
and indeed had we all been you know
fighting for a labor win at that
election I think there's every
possibility that we would have won it
and we would have been in the process
now of transforming the country but look
you know Tony Ben used to say that the
labor party needs two wings to fly I
mean I was a member of the labor party
for best part of 43 years and you know I
always had respect for people of all
shades of opinion within the labor party
I was on the left I supported Jeremy
corbyn obviously
um and I naively anticipated thought
that when he was overwhelmingly elected
in that one Member One vote election in
2015 then re-elected with an even bigger
margin actually but in the 2015 one in
particular I thought that all these
right Wingers in the labor party many of
whom were friends of mine when I was in
the house from 2010 to 2015 a loss
proceeding came back in 2017 would
accept the Democratic will of the
members I accepted the Democratic will
of the party when they elected Tony
Blair I didn't agree with his politics
but I I worked for the labor party I
felt the labor party was the best
vehicle to deliver Progressive social
change but what it's shown to me is that
Tony Ben's uh assumption that the party
needs two wings to fly was based on a
false premise but the truth is Christmas
had never been in the ascendancy the
left had never been in the ascendancy
then Jeremy got elected it and the right
wing of the labor party who are in the
pockets of the war machine in the
pockets of the establishment were not
prepared to accept that Democratic will
and to work for a labor it sounds like a
contradiction of terms the right wing of
a socialist party but anyway
um you you tweeted out today uh that the
labor party is utterly lost and I think
we've got it on screen uh the job now is
to is to destroy the labor party so you
essentially uh Chris seem to want to
um destroy both wings and build
something completely different how are
you going to do that or are you going to
do that with with Jeremy corbyn based on
his uh his statement this evening
well
well well I've not seen Jeremy statement
this evening but let's see what what
happens but um it will be very difficult
obviously particularly in a system that
we have electoral system in this country
the first past the post system you know
mitigates against you know new parties
emerging although we've seen it happen
in in Scotland you've just been talking
about the SMP they've actually destroyed
eviscerated the labor party in Scotland
labor was dominant for years in Scotland
wasn't it and of course indeed in in you
know in the whole of the country you
know back at the turn of the uh 20th
century uh the labor party replaced the
liberals so you know it's not impossible
but I accept that it's difficult but
look look the labor party you know isn't
what people thought it was in reality it
is a tool of the establishment and to
varying degrees it always has been but
it's openly nakedly admitted that fact
now as I've said it's in the pocket of
the walking scene it's in the pocket of
uh so Chris just to clarify I'm not
interested they're not interested in
transforming the country we are
neoliberals to the call wow um just to
clarify what Jeremy corbyn said is is
that uh secure stama's statement about
my future is a flagrant attack on the
Democratic rights of Islington North
labor party members
I mean they're not interested in
democracy I mean that's been pretty
clear isn't it we've seen that you know
I mean you know when I was leading the
campaign to democratize the labor party
and touring the country and the
Democracy Roadshow uh getting you know
huge attendances of members were really
energized and engaged with the agenda
that Jeremy corbyn was putting forward
with this possibility of democratizing
the party putting the members in the
driving seat I'm used to quote Ed
miliband in those meetings who said in
2010 that if we'd listen to our members
a bit more when we were in government we
wouldn't have made as many mistakes he
was absolutely right there wouldn't have
been tuition fees introduced there
wouldn't have been a war in Iraq there
wouldn't have been cut on the Social
Security benefits for the poorest people
in the country and Chris I mean you're
obviously incredibly angry tonight I
wonder how many labor MPS in the
Parliamentary party you think still
identify more with Jeremy corbyn's view
of the world your view of the world you
two share roughly the same thing the
than they do with Kia stormers and how
is that going to play out
well look I mean the the tragedy is that
the uh socialist campaign group of Labor
MPS have been uh left wanting really I
mean there's a line in the the labor
Party Anthem the red flag though cowards
Flinch and traitor sneer and I'm afraid
to say that the Parliamentary labor
party is exclusively made up of cowards
and traitors and I put the Socialist
campaign group within the Christmas
category because they weren't prepared
to speak out against they weren't
prepared to speak out against the Witch
Hunt against long-standing anti-racists
are you talking about yourself they
weren't prepared to defend even Jeremy
corbyn hang on Chris uh secure Starman
had the courage uh to tackle the high
levels of anti-Semitism within the party
which huge announced you still deny it
that's utter not well of course I do
because the figures prove that that was
a lie it was nonsense now what happened
was the labor party foolishly embraced
the ihra the international Holocaust
remembrance uh alliances definitely
additional working definition of of
anti-Semitism and there's a range of
different examples
to bring in what no no no we'll know
every decent person accepts it at all
actually because what it means is that
criticism of the the racist settler
Colonial apartheid regime in Israel is
now deemed anti-Semitism if you look at
the examples I think there are six or
seven of the 11 I think it is examples
in the ihra working definition which
actually cite criticism of of Israel as
a form of anti-Semitism finest is a very
straightforward concept it's hatred or
bigotry against Jewish people because
they're Jews and the interesting thing
is now for all kirstan is saying that
always you know he's eradicated
anti-Semitism in the labor party Jewish
people are being thrown out of the labor
party hand over fist because they oppose
the apartheid regime
let's keep this simple that's the point
not about not about anti-Semitism let us
keep this simple are you saying that the
party never really had a problem it
didn't truly have a problem
no he did not have a problem not the
labor party has been in my wow I mean I
think there were multiple instances
and no no there hasn't been multiple
incidents that's an absolute lie Chris
it sounds like that ridiculous report of
the ehrc well in a minute the ehrc
report they were only able to cite two
examples of of anti-Semitism and that
was on the basis upon which they then
you know produced their report and
suggested that you know the labor had a
a major problem with anti-Semitism and
even those two cases are subject to
judicials and there was a very strong
case and they will probably be thrown
out
you have nothing and and that complaint
that complaint was put forward in the
first place thank you very much
related groups who wanted to undermine
the labor party pretty remarkable used
to you're still into now thank you very
much Chris Williamson MP just not a
denial
I'm telling the facts
Kevin storm has done the right thing in
your view I mean well hang on what do
you make of that yeah you can just let
that long yeah well Kirsten would not
allow or most labor MPS would not want
Chris Williamson back in the labor party
now or probably not on TV either no in
truth I'd be quite happy to be attacked
on the basis that uh that Chris has used
now that
there's always a kernel of Truth
somewhere but the labor did have a
problem and anti-Semitism was weaponized
both by those against corbyn and those
who supported Corbin that's a fact but
Kia starmet will point to huge poll
leads and how he's transformed labor
since 2019 and they got the worst
drubbing since 1935. in terms of seats
yeah the fact is he is very
authoritarian though I think the the the
what what we've just seen with Chris
Williamson here is still this kind of
ideological possession which Kirsten has
tried to root out which is why I say
there's not a lot of differences between
the Tories and the labor party at the
moment as well because one thing he said
was they're neoliberals to the call
guess what some of the Tories right and
what kirstan has tried to do is kind of
Wipe Out the more extreme very
ideologically pure aspects of this party
and keep it more Centrist keep it more
palatable he's talking about
transforming the country you know
politicians actually saying that now
feel a bit scary because you know what
kind of transformation are you are you
going to are you trying to on the
question of corbyn though he is more
authoritarian on selection oh absolutely
now during the Corbin era people were
stopped from standing and they rigged uh
selections and so on and had people
suspended so their seats could be taken
by other people that all happened under
corbyn too however right here Stormer
has taken it to a new level yeah and
trying to palletize the party
the poles show he's justified in doing
it absolutely next tonight bake offs
Dame Brew Leaf lobbies MPS to legalize
assisted dying but her MP son disagrees
and he joins us next
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no with the people's
Channel no word of use every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you yeah
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
welcome back well MPS are holding an
inquiry into assisted dying for the
first time in almost 20 years they're
asking people whether if people who have
a terminal illness should be allowed to
end their own lives a very very
difficult question now public support
for a change in the law has actually
grown pretty substantially but assisting
death is still currently punishable by
up to 14 years in prison and critics
fear that a legal change could put
pressure on vulnerable people to end
their lives a new documentary fronted by
bake off's prolith and her son the
conservative MP Danny Krueger takes a
look at both sides of the debate
when it was time and they had set 10
o'clock to drink their medicine
we went into the bedroom and we just sat
in silence and love and just held this
space for them as they
drifted to sleep
my mom passed in 15 minutes
and my dad passed about 45 minutes later
but they both went to sleep within a
fume within a few minutes yeah
yeah and died holding hands
that's a wonderful story
wow that is going to be some documentary
that's on tomorrow night well Danny
Krueger who would disagree with his mum
that it's a wonderful story joins us now
in the studio and former conservative
cabinet minister kit moat house who is
speaking in a personal capacity is down
the line uh good evening to you both
um Danny I mean this is such a such an
emotional debate so difficult for
everybody it's it's it's not on party
lines you know you two conservatives
obviously completely the other side of
the debate but it does seem to me you
know surely
I mean we don't treat dogs the way we
allowed humans to suffer
yeah why can't we do better well the
comparison is interesting you know a dog
is a pet we own a pet and we ultimately
decide on their life nobody owns a human
being and what the assistant dying law
would mean is that a doctor has the
power to decide that somebody's better
off dead and to prescribe a lethal
injection to that person I totally
recognize why so many people think that
it's a good idea and I really do believe
in the autonomy of the individual but
actually what I need to really hold out
for and kit and I as MPS have to
consider is the wider implication what
about the vulnerable what about the
disabled the lonely mentally ill and my
mother and I went to Canada and you just
showed you know the one Great Clip uh on
the other side of this debate there are
lots of there's lots of footage in the
TV program and you just look online
search Canada assisted dying and you'll
see story after Story of vulnerable
people who have felt pressured into this
step their families find out they've
been euthanized after it has happened
because nobody has to tell them there's
so many bad stories coming out of Canada
and all the other countries where it's
legal that we should not stop there are
also really awful stories that come out
of Europe aren't there I mean I'm
thinking you probably know the details
better than I do but there are cases
where very young people who've been
suffering from profound mental health
difficulties but no physical illness
have been allowed to go down this awful
that's the case everywhere so there's
not a single jurisdiction where assisted
dying is legal where you're not also
eligible if you have an eating disorder
if you if you're if you can convince the
doctor that you're near to death right
because of a mental health condition or
anorexia or diabetes people with hernias
and cancer are getting it all you need
to do is convince the doctor you're
eligible and the and they sign it for
you well let's let's bring in Morehouse
kit thanks for joining us I mean
such an emotional debate but Danny here
essentially saying that we're not
capable of Designing a a framework of
regulations
and the necessary checks and balances I
mean surely come on we're smart enough
to be able to do that aren't we
well that's certainly my view and and
you know Danny cites the the situation
in Canada very often as a comparison
um but if we uh followed that uh kind of
principle then we wouldn't necessarily
have an abortion or they have no legal
restrictions on abortion at any stage in
Canada and yet we design a law in our
own country that is for our own values
the other thing that we need to stress
of course is that the situation in this
country at the moment the status quo is
horrible I mean we've got you know one
person a week on average going to
Switzerland to take their own life at
dignitas you know we've got several
hundred people every year with terminal
diseases committing suicide in horrible
circumstances and thousands of people
um dying horrible undignified deaths and
that's before you even get into the the
position of doctors helping people on
their way
so the situation in the country in the
UK at the moment is
is stressing for thousands if not
millions of people
um and and it's just not acceptable and
and we do believe you know I chair the
all-party group in Parliament and I work
with ding and said dying we do believe
that it is possible for us to design a
law with faith country
how do you feel do you feel that you've
been somewhat sort of dragged into this
debate by your dear mother because it
may not have been a cause that you
necessarily would have chosen I know
well I did choose it I mean it is
slightly her fault because when I became
an MP she asked me to help her with the
campaign yeah for four legalized uh
assisted suicide I'd always been quite
uh iffy about the topic I didn't like it
in principle to begin with but I said I
would look into it so I looked into it
my prejudices were confirmed you know I
really think it's dangerous so no I
think it's very important I don't like
disagreeing with my mom she she and Kate
I really respect the arguments on the
other side I would just agree agree with
kit though it's absolutely unacceptable
in the state of the end of life care
that people receive in this country
every year thousands of people die very
very badly that is not an argument for
killing them it's an argument for
improving palliative care which we can
do I'm really hoping we may now be able
to get Kit back I'm sorry about that kit
we just had to correct the line there um
can you tell us is there a particular
reason why you personally feel so
strongly about this issue it's quite a
really difficult one for any politician
well it is and to be honest with you
many people come to the cause after
they've had horrible personal experience
of somebody who they love or a friend
who's died in in awful circumstances and
who wanted this kind of
um uh service if you like or wanted this
Choice uh for their own life and
certainly I've experienced it in my own
family albeit my um if you like my
decision about this uh particular course
of policy came well before that in my
teens I I've always had in myself the
sense that I wanted in extremists the
ability to choose the time place and
manner of my own death and I would want
that for everybody who needed it or
indeed wanted it and of course you don't
have to have it if you don't want it but
this is one of the the things about
assisted dying is that for many people
who are facing a terminal illness they
know broadly what's going to happen to
them you know if you have motor neurone
disease you know that at the end of your
life you're basically going to choke to
death and no amount of palliative
but knowing that if you need it you can
choose assisting allows you to enjoy in
much more security what time you have
left just before I come to Daddy we
wanted to find out from our own uh
viewers and listeners uh with a quick
poll this evening so we asked uh we
asked for and there's the results 61 in
favor 39 against which I think the
yougov poll is actually slightly
stronger in favor it does seem to have
moved I think back in about 2015 MPS
Danny voted against overwhelmingly over
300 against no public opinions
does that worry you I mean you so I
think polls are valuable and interesting
I mean polls generally show a majority
in favor of his sister dying because if
you are someone the simple question do
you think which people who are you know
facing an agonizing death should be
allowed to have a an early termination
then people will instinctively say yes
well the evidence also shows and there's
lots of polling to prove this once you
explain to them what it actually means
what the implication or how it would
work in practice how it's working in
other countries the support drops away
and that's why MPS
we've Parliament has looked at this half
a dozen times over just in this century
and every time they conclude not to go
down this road because they actually
study it and I think that'll happen
again you touched on palliative care I
mean if that was much better yeah and if
if
pain drugs were much better I mean I've
seen it they are good now so I'm afraid
you're writing Kit's right too many
people have have personal experience of
loved ones dying really badly that was
my mother's experience two of her
brother died badly right it should not
be happening we have enormous strides in
analgesic pain relief and nobody should
die in physical Agony anymore including
people with mnd by the way that's just
very quickly do you want to have one
see I mean as I say I do think it's
possible for us to design a law that
fits for the UK and fits our own values
notwithstanding what other countries
around the world do and the implication
of Danny's argument is the Canadians the
Australians the French are now looking
at other countries they're somehow
barbaric and that we're we're going to
be well which of those questions do you
want to adopt kid because none of them
were or in any of those you can in the
same way that we have an abortion law
for our own circumstances governed by
our own Parliament I think we should
have a law that that allows people to
choose the time and place of their death
and extreme it's not safe anywhere else
I'm going to finish it and it it can be
safe in the same way that our abortion
law is
a tough question
um is it actually genuinely one for MPS
or dare I say should it be a referendum
Daddy
I think this is one where the right
process is for it to be properly looked
at not just a snap poll so yeah I think
it's something for Parliament to
regulate
um kit
oh yeah definitely something for
Parliament to regulate I mean and the
point about it is that Parliament is not
doing that at the moment and as a result
we have an unregulated uh situation
where lots of people are taking their
deaths in horrible circumstances taking
their own lives in horrible
circumstances who would rather have the
choice to do it with dignity
thank you very much for coming on and
from your bravery on confronting what is
a really very difficult issue I'm really
looking forward to seeing I'm not sure
looking forward is the word but I think
it'll be it looks as it would be a very
powerful documentary
um it's it's so difficult but if I can
just be sort of brutal about it on the
politics of it this is an issue that I
don't think I cannot see any government
taking on it's the kind of thing that
comes up in a private member's Bill and
go and tends to go nowhere I mean
governments run a mile from the abortion
debate and this is in the same sort of
category they will not want to touch so
I actually think you're you know from
your point of view you're going to be
okay your mother may not be quite quite
so pleased I don't see it happening I
just saw a friend die in absolute agony
with bone cancer and it was it was
heartbreaking and the drugs just
couldn't deal with it maybe if the drugs
have improved the palliative care has
improved uh maybe that um that's the way
through it well um thank you very much
fascinating
uh next tonight call
called GP stop signing so many people
off work
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
well coming up on the talk tonight
police reveal missing mum Nicola bully
was vulnerable and had significant
issues with alcohol Nicholas sturgeon
steps down as Scottish first minister so
what does that mean for Independence and
a major scientific breakthrough with the
male contraceptive pill we'll be talking
about all of that at nine o'clock
welcome back well Esther and Kevin are
back with us as our fantastic Superstar
panel at that debate just before the
breakup on assisted dying so difficult
so emotional so personal where are you
Kevin first on this oh look I think it's
barbaric that we force people condemn
people to live in agony when they when
they want to ease their passing it's a
debate we have to have if you don't
believe in a sister dying don't do it
yourself but why stop other people and
there's huge contradictions when now
we've got the money you can be taken to
dignitas and Switzerland if you've got
the money and the people who take you
won't be prosecuted doctors turn off
life support machines in hospitals every
day in consultation with with families
now assisted dying it'll make us a more
civilized country do you think labor
might pick it up as a as an issue or
just two different yeah they've been
tiptoeing around it but I think you have
to make it a cross party
I I think I think it's clearly a moral
issue I think when you have cases like
what we've been seeing in Canada
happening where it's clearly gone too
far you have these undercover patients
going to doctors and they'll be having
conversation about their chronic pain
and then casually in conversation they
talk about also euthanasian is an option
you know that that just shows that it
does go a step too far so that that is
the worry though I think I don't think
the country is ready for it I don't
think we have the appetite for it this
is still I know it sounds shocking a
Christian country and we we still we
base a lot of our laws on on Christian
morality and I just don't think it's
rightful I think we'll go in one way
it's just when we get there oh really I
mean what is appalling is a situation
where you've got loving spouses
and their their dying partners are
begging for help to die and that loving
spouse and there have been multiple
court cases over this is put in an
utterly invidious position totally
tragic and they in the end cave into the
desperate appeals to help and find
themselves hauled through the court yeah
what criminal is they could be up on a
charge not that they've actually I I
think that that I do think that that is
where we could have a discussion on
actually not Prosecuting people that
assist people to die I do think with
safeguards exactly but if it's not
abroad I think that's a different case
but I do think in the UK this is there
shouldn't be a country that legalizes
that talking of safeguards and other
issues uh a different sort of aspect of
being the front page the telegraph today
classic sort of uh Tory you know
rattling the flag sick note Crackdown to
boost Workforce this is a hobby horse of
yours I know it's a hobby horse it is
actually one of the hoppy horses I think
can quite approval well I did I did
actually uh give a press conference at
the beginning of the year saying that I
wanted to in order to make Britain work
and we've actually got to make work pay
and get many of the 5.2 million people
on how to work benefits back into work
absolutely look my starting point is
always if you can work you've got to
work yeah if you can't do something you
might be able to do something else but
at the same time there are some people
who are sick and disabled and they've
got to be looked after now this felt
though reading the story and the time it
just felt a bit of it's It's a
parliamentary recess
it's not pathetic the figures actually
tell their own stories don't they I mean
there's been a huge rise in people on
sick notes since the pandemic 25 yeah a
lot but long covert is a medically
recognized is a medically recognized
condition 300 000 plus people donated
were covered of course Millions more had
it with it you're gonna get a tail from
it
look the thing is I think this is
pathetic right because I think this is
really skirting around the issue the
point is we shouldn't be living in a
country where there are more jobs
available than people to fill those jobs
and we're working for able-bodied people
is is is an option right where they can
choose not to work and they can still
live you know not very well we've got
one in eight of the working age
population on out of work benefits it's
one and a half million more
and if if you're right and you say there
are a few then tackle those few and you
can come in with a system to look at
that but don't don't just think
Britain's become suddenly work shy a
nation of Scholars
being employed well you shouldn't be
able to
tune I think the way the benefit system
is now people can choose no but you can
choose because the thing is there are
people then why are there more jobs
available than people to film anyone
who's dealt with the DW Department of
work and pensions know how tough it is
I'm sorry I have actually dealt with
them
young people I've had young people
because I work for anyway I had young
people coming to sit there telling me
I'm a software engineer and I'm not
going to do a job that's not in software
engineering it's like well excuse me you
don't have a choice you're 20.
it's not sick or disabled is it it's not
what Richard
what I'm hearing though for example is
you've got taxi drivers in Northern
towns who are working out that they can
earn more instead of driving five days a
week they'll drive 16 hours a week
they'll be on benefits and are their net
take-home pay is more that's a terrible
situation for a nation to get in so one
of the situations the system's flawed
it's broken but the benefit system is
designed you will you will always get
more in work it's just where that work
pays enough
that's no longer how it's working
because of course benefits have been
increased but they've Frozen the tax
threshold there's another danger that
long covered just becomes a bit of a
catch-all uh yeah
in the few cases I don't think it's a
few I think it's a lot more than you're
willing way more than a few I don't
think we've become a nation of malingers
choosing not to work has become a
legitimate option and that is a problem
about the 1980s Kevin you've got to make
work pay by lifting the personal tax
threshold above the standard threshold
for benefits yeah well you make work pay
by raising Wages that's how
we're all going to keep working around
this table that's it from us anyway
wherever you are whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel nobody
use every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking